Syrian government forces backed by
Russian airstrikes are bombarding a
rebel Enclave on the outskirts of
Damascus for a fourth day more than 250
people are reported dead in the assault
on the heavily populated area medical
clinics are among the facilities hurt
these strikes on Eastern goota
are described as among the worst against
civilians in the seven-year-old war
Jonathan Vigliotti is following
developments from London Jonathan good
morning good morning government-run
media in Syria calls reports of an
assault lies and deceptions but graphic
images from the ground show the reality
of what is an escalating civil war that
has civilians trapped in the middle
government airstrikes pummeled the
already skeletal area of Goethe as
civilians on the ground scrambled to
find safety Syria's Volunteer Ambulance
Service the white helmets captured the
chaos the wounded rushed to hospitals
overflowing with victims this father
like so many other parents outlived his
son dr. Ahmed Tarek ji is the president
of the syrian american medical society
who has teams working in goota two of
his staff were killed the past 48 hours
equals or is very comparable to what
we've seen in the last two days in
Aleppo and those are the peak of the
deterioration of the hematuria situation
inside Syria the rebel-held enclave of
Goethe on the outskirts of the capital
damascus has been under siege for more
than five years as the Syrian regime
backed by Russian allies crushed rebels
who they say have been shelling the
capital killing civilians the people of
Goethe are still living in fear after
the 2013 chemical attack that shocked
the world
it is a lawless society where rebels
have used humans as shields and where
government forces have died
families are all packed in small
basements so just a matter of you know
them praying hoping that the missile
will miss their basement so hunger is
one factor but they're waiting for death
and pro-government forces are reportedly
preparing a new ground assault dr. Tarzi
says he knows families who want to leave
but can't
they're worried government forces who
control checkpoints will consider them
rebels and kill them Gayle all right
thank you very much Jonathan